olav courier was born in 1992 and to
resew sweden as a kid olaf loved to play
soccer but when a severe knee injury
kept him away from his soccer ambitions
for a full year he filled his time with
counter-strike familiar with the 1.16
olaf began his competitive career in
2009 with team ik winter shortly after
shifting over as a stand-in on rage
gaming 2012 saw the release of Counter
Strike global Offensive and Olaf
alongside Crim's
and Dennis would begin to fight for LGBT
sports in this new era it didn't take
long for LGBT to rise as one of the best
teams in Europe after putting up a heavy
fight at several events not really our
first month we knew they had talent but
can you believe they not phonetic else
yeah but Olaf really put himself on the
map when feet would bring him to fnatic
mid 2014 fnatic would go on to win a
series of events such as star series X
faceit League season 2 and ESEA season
17 but Olaf's most memorable moment lies
in his performance in Dreamhack winter
2014 where they faced ldl-c gaming in
the quarterfinals and berth his iconic
nickname the boost meister straight
headshot they have no ideas dismiss
looking confused and dazed and it's
going to be a follower
because I be kidding me takes out here
steamer as well down 13 to 3 after the
first 16 rounds fnatic successfully
pulled off a three-man boost on overpass
giving olofmeister clear vision down
several key areas around the map they
pick up the round notice plug the tactic
was deemed illegal and fnatic would go
on to forfeit their rematch against ldlc
and I guess for fate the match between
against no DLC okay
I met the team and we have talked into
they don't want to say the biggest of
the Americas and they have felt that
they have been no cues from the court
the Year 2015 would be the year fnatic
would cement themselves as one of if not
the most dominant team to ever play
counter-strike
ladies and gentlemen cavity fit champion
South Pacific ten international titles
and two back-to-back wins at a valve
sponsored event these accomplishments
would solidify olofmeister as the best
player in the world in the year 2016
Olaf would continue to leave fnatic in
terms of ratings he shined brightest
that year at IEM katowice a leading the
tournament charged with 300 frags and
claiming his second MVP award even what
automated assists like one of the
biggest tournaments of the year and like
this is super important so of course and
with the major I think that's another
message that for everything that they
should be scared for us despite their
dominance at the major event
Olaf began to express a problem in his
right arm it remains unclear as to
exactly what his injury entails but it
proved to be detrimental as the Swedish
powerhouse were upset at MLG Columbus
sit down
it's DWF at match point for a throne
it's a double you need the blood we've
seen it before we need to see it again
me out of a skin for his team to survive
it but a few many angles too many
Estrada players zero computer have to go
with products people I think just as a
note to all of us having a bad game he
did come in to determine saying that he
has a rich father is and I think it
shows here I mean he's not really but
this part of your mapping wasn't really
playing up to par bottom of the
scoreboard didn't really have much of
the impact with Olaf's rating in the red
for the first time that year Olaf was
forced to take an indefinite hiatus from
the game when I play like at the meter
it was kind of locking in or like that's
like cramps and locking anthems we would
young from different place and right now
that's all gone
Ike when I first started I wasn't that
afraid I was like I was kind of I don't
know not happy but it was like okay to
get some time off
it was command that I needed even with
Olaf's return fnatic began to drop in
performance which led to a roster swap
with god-sent
Trading JW Crim's and flusher from
fnatic
and twist and electro from godsend this
sparked a lot of drama and confusion
among fanatic fans and the team just did
not click after a couple months fnatic
would switch back to their roster with
olofmeister near healthy and the lineup
back together fnatic and Olaf look to
make their way to the top of the world
standings and said I don't think I'm the
best player but I think there's nobody
that amounts of the same thing the final
but it yeah maybe it is
I don't know thanks for watching if you
want more great content be sure to hit
that subscribe button
[Music]